bonjour ou plutôt bonsoir à tous il me
fait vraiment très bizarre de faire
cette vidéo car ça y est enfin j'ai vu
star wars 9 et enfin on va en parler et
je me sens encore vraiment assez
perturbé parce qu on est quand même à la
fin de la saga
enfin la fin de l'histoire des skywalker
enfin la saga principale est
techniquement fini quoi vraiment fini
donc on va essayer de commencer avec une
partie sans spoiler puis continue avec
une partie spoiler mais je ne suis
vraiment pas un expert du sang spoiler
du coup ça va être assez court mais
avant tout sachez que cette vidéo est
sponsorisé oui comme vous le savez
maintenant je ne suis plus étudiant il
faut que j'arrive à vivre de mes propres
moyens et surtout c'est une sponso qui
normalement devrait vous plaire car il
ya un gros concours à la clé où je vais
pouvoir vous faire gagner le contenu de
ce que je vais vous présenter comme je
viens de le mentionner
cette vidéo est sponsorisé par woods
boxe nous sommes donc sur une box
exclusivement star wars est fait pour
l'occasion on est quand même sur la
sortie star wars 9 il faut fêter ça
alors je sais que ça peut faire peur à
certains mais il faut préciser qu'étant
donné que cette box et exclusive est
conçu pour l'occasion
la boxe et sans engagement c'est un
achat unique et surtout c'est une box à
quantité limitée il ne faudra pas trop
tarder si vous souhaitez l'acquérir
concernant son contenu nous sommes face
à des produits parfaitement officielle
et de la licence star wars et ça je ne
vous cache pas que c'est un gros point
fort nous avons tout d'abord une tasse
tu tentes trooper avec l'emblème de l'
empire
rassurez vous pour l'avoir testé c'est
bien une tasse qui passe au micro ondes
le second produit et une casquette
officielle de la licence avec le logo
star wars
elle est vraiment très sobre mais je
trouve qu'elle fait vraiment le taf
personnellement pour continuer nous
avons un t-shirt avec pour illustration
la flotte de l' empire nous pouvons
clairement faire le rapprochement avec
star wars neuf ou cette flotte nous est
apparu dans les trailers et enfin le
clou du spectacle est possiblement le
meilleur produit de la boîte
la figurine pop
de kayes lorraine avec son design de
star wars neuf qu'on retrouve notamment
dans son casque bon comme vous l'aurez
remarqué nous sommes sur une box plutôt
orienté bad guys avec lempire la flotte
impériale ou directement caille lorraine
si vous souhaitez avoir cette box star
wars limitée déjà sachez que ça ferait
un bon cadeau de noël et oui mais
surtout vous avez un lien dans la
description vous permettant de vous la
procurer et point non négligeable si
vous utilisez le code promo argot rock 7
vous obtiendrez une réduction de 7 roule
sur votre achat mais ce n'est pas fini
car oui j'ai négocié également de mon
côté pour que vous puissiez gagner une
de ces box pour ça rien de plus simple
je vous organise ce concours sur mon
instagram et oui c'est une première bref
toutes les modalités sont dans la
description à vous d'aller jeter un oeil
alors je suis à la fois content et en
même temps c'est très bizarre je ne
saurais pas décrire ce sentiment je suis
content car la saga quand même cette
nouvelle trilogie se termine sur un bon
film star wars ne fait vraiment très
bien franchement et surtout en plus il
apporte des réponses c'est vraiment ce
que je voulais néanmoins en même temps
je les trouvais trop biousse par moments
mais en même temps je me dis est ce que
c'est vraiment le film qui est à blâmer
car en tant que fans et surtout grâce à
ma chaîne youtube c c'est normal que moi
je me renseigne de partout que j'essaye
de voir toutes les options possibles
pour les futurs des films et c'est donc
en même temps je savais beaucoup de
choses en même temps je savais rien et
en même temps j'étais ultra y paie quoi
et puis en plus vraiment j'ai regardé 0
liqun vraiment je n'ai pas regardé le
15e l'oeuvre le truc c'est que voilà on
est quand même sur star wars c'est le
début de la chaîne techniquement c'est
l'identité de départ de la chaîne on a
commencé avec star wars est on arrive à
la fin
star wars 9 la conclusion ça fait
vraiment bizarre il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de hype et maintenant tout
commence à redescendre et c'est
peut-être ce sentiment l'objet dans tous
les cas ce star wars neuf et je trouve
une bonne conclusion vraiment
le film est très bien mais après il
n'est pas exempte de défauts évidemment
on est vraiment sûr du jj abrams
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
comme dans star wars est il ya
énormément de références et c'est un
petit peu la douche jj abrams dans star
wars j'ai l'impression c'est que il ya
aussi dans star wars 9 beaucoup de
références
alors ce n'est pas un mal du tout en
franchement moi j'ai plutôt bien aimé
franchement mais je sais pas si ceux qui
n'ont pas aimé star wars vont aimer star
wars 9 sais pas si vous comprenez
vraiment l'idée en fait le truc c'est
que tout s'enchaîne ultra vite mais en
même temps j'avais ce sentiment là pour
avengers endgame bizarrement parce que
le truc c'est que en même temps l excuse
on est quand même sur une conclusion
vraiment comme avengers endgame avec
marvel et du coup je le comprends il
faut balancer il faut fermer les portes
qui ont été ouvertes et surtout il faut
rester cohérent par rapport à ce qu'a
fait ryan johnson avec star wars 8 est
ce qu'il y a raconté et oui je vais me
répéter encore mais pour moi vraiment la
plus grande faiblesse de cette nouvelle
trilogie c'est le fait que à chaque
nouvel épisode on écrit l'histoire et on
change de réalisateur on écrit tout
petit à petit et pourtant je trouve que
cette nouvelle trilogie apporte vraiment
beaucoup de choses et a vraiment plus
d'un tour dans son sac
donc tout est lié au passé c'est normal
mais surtout connaissant jj abrams à
l'avant ce ballet référence au passé
allait pleuvoir mais vraiment je trouve
que ça l'a été bien fait vraiment
vraiment je suis sincère enfin voila je
sais pas trop quoi dire de plus pour
toute la partie sans spoil je suis pas
très bon là dessus donc ce que je vous
propose c'est qu'on passe maintenant la
partie spoiler ou là on va pouvoir un
peu plus se lâcher et aller plus en
profondeur
nous avons tout d'abord le retour de
palpatine et je ne sais pas enfin je
trouve ça très très audacieux je trouve
ça même limite culotté de faire revenir
palpatine
parce que palpatine c'est ça veut dire
qu'il ya beaucoup derrière quoi si on
fait revenir palpatine car vraiment pour
moi il était mort dans star wars 6 et
pour moi il y avait aucune raison qu'ils
survivent
après ils pouvaient je sais qui dans
l'univers étendu
enfin si c'est l'univers étendu le
problème c'est que suis pas expert star
wars non plus quoi mais je sais qu'au
final il survit entre guillemets il
passe de corps en corps il me semble son
esprit passe de corps en corps comme on
le voit un peu avec le real a faim il
il utilise un peu le même procédé fin
ils l'expliquent
mais techniquement il ne devrait plus
avoir de corps physique pour moi car
après l'épisode 6 quand même genre il
est mort dans une explosion l'explosion
de l'étoile de la mort et c'est ça m'a
fait bizarre de le revoir en chair et en
os quoi mais je respecte ce choix au
final et j'étais très content de revoir
palpatine néanmoins est ce que je me
demande c'est est ce que ce ne serait
pas là un peu la solution de facilité de
faire revenir pas de patine car le truc
c'est que si on fait revenir palpatine
c'est que
palpatine c'est le mec qui est à
l'origine de tout en fait
non tout star wars tous les conflits
cetera il a toujours été le mal et du
coup le faire revenir encore une fois je
me demande est ce que ce serait pas un
peu facile surtout que du coup bah
évidemment il était derrière ce nom il
est derrière les voix de kylie rennes
qui étaient en sa tête et surtout il est
derrière tout le background de ré
également en fait c'est le point ce
genre le point qui réunit tous il est
également à l'origine de l'exil de l'udc
qui au final était à sa recherche
tout ça au final c'est comme si tout
était réuni pour palpatine en mode c'est
la solution le problème c'est palpatine
si on le détruit tout est gagné
mais en même temps on pouvait pas faire
mieux je pense que l'empereur pour avoir
une vraie menace qui marque pour la fin
de ce star wars neuf et je trouve quand
même que
on était vraiment sûr du palpatine là
c'était vraiment du palpatine qui
manigancent tout de a à z qui manipule
qui manipulent kyle lorraine qui
manipulent arrêt qui manipule tout le
monde on était vraiment sur lui
palpatine et ça a été bien respectée je
trouve et j'étais franchement assez
content quand même de revoir palpatine
jeu là vous donc il ya des défauts mais
il ya aussi des qualités évidemment mais
surtout en fait je sais plus vraiment où
maintenir par rapport à l'univers étendu
en fait parce que du coup ça c'est
quelque chose que je ne maîtrise pas
vraiment l'univers étendu de star wars
et il ya des trucs que maintenant on
fait disney prend en compte et qu avant
il avait tout mis de côté en mode non ça
c'est pas dans les films sasany essaya
rien ça aucun rapport et maintenant
salées donc après je sais que darth
plagueis était quand même considérer
comme quelques quelqu'un de canon dans
les films puisque palpatine en parle
dans l'épisode 3 il ya même une
référence assailant il dit exactement la
même phrase que dans star wars iii
moment avec des pouvoirs considéré comme
comme contraire à la nature je me
souviens plus exactement
enfin voilà pas son arrêt reste je suis
je crois que c'est à cause d'elle en
fait que j'ai ce sentiment bizarre moi
parce qu'en même temps j'aime beaucoup
rire franchement c'est un je trouve
c'est un super personnage je trouve
qu'elle apporte vraiment beaucoup et c
est je voulais absolument des réponses
sur ses origines etc
c'était vraiment je pense la chose que
je souhaitais le plus dans toute cette
nouvelle trilogie depuis star wars 7 mai
pourquoi ce choix en fait pourquoi
palpatine pourquoi regrets palpatine si
j'arrive pas
comprendre vraiment l'idée derrière tout
ça je me dis encore que c'est un peu une
sorte de solution de facilité quoi il
faut trouver des origines arrêts ont
fait revenir palpatine
elle élit à palpatine ses limites trop
facile est ce que je me demande c'est ce
que c'est vraiment une pure invention ou
est-ce qu'il ya quand même une
inspiration derrière tout ça parce que
je connais pas trop l'histoire de
palpatine et je crois qu'elle est pas
très très connu non plus mais je sais
pas si s'il a eu une descendance par la
suite
et puis surtout comment justifier ça
dans le film est ce que palpatine avait
une femme au final c'est je suis
vraiment perturbé par rapport à ça et je
pense qu'il faudrait que je revoie star
wars 9 et même que je me renseigne plus
de mon côté parce que j'avoue que je
suis vraiment perturbé par rapport à ça
en tout cas ce choix il est fait il est
présent je le respecte un franchement
c'est pas non plus une mauvaise idée en
soi puisque après tout s'il faut
vraiment donner des origines et après
sort était l'enfant de kii techniquement
donc le fait que ce soit palpatine
apporte des choses quand même plutôt
intéressantes dont la dyade avec cai
lorraine effectivement comme le laissait
supposer trailer et c'est quelque chose
que je pensais grandement avec ce star
wars neuf c'est que voilà reka lorraine
était toujours en confrontation et qu'au
final il fallait pour moi qu'ils
s'unissent pour justement trouvé raison
et réussir
là où ils n'arrêtent pas de pêcher à
chaque fois quoi et c'est ça que je
trouve hyper intéressant parce que du
coup l'union fait la force
et surtout pas n'importe quelle union
l'union d'un skywalker et d'une
palpatine deux noms qui n'ont pas du
tout la même origine des skywalker c'est
vraiment le symbole du jedi des
chevaliers jedi et puis palpatine bah du
coup c'est le symbole c'est le nom du
mal des seigneurs sith
du coup sith et jedi et sith et jedi
réunis du coup techniquement mais juste
de par leur nom je veux dire c'est pas
genre assez inde j'ai des c'est pas
genre est une véritable g d'ail et
qu'elle aurait un véritable site mais
leurs noms ont un lourd passé et ils ont
toujours été en confrontation comme des
aimants et ça c'est un symbole que j'ai
trouvé vraiment très fort et très très
intéressant dans ce star wars dont
quelque chose que j'ai trouvé par contre
un petit peu où je suis un peu plus
mitigé c'est par rapport à ses parents
du coup les parents de reste du coup
sont des nobody un ces personnes c'est
il était contre palpatine qui voulaient
du coup sa petite fille et ils ont voulu
la sauver la protéger ils l'ont laissée
sur jack ou soit mais du coup
au point genre querelles change de nom
tu vois je sais pas genre c'est en même
temps je comprends elle a toujours été
entourée skywalker du coup elle se
considère comme une skywalker et son nom
est un nom très lourd à porter un c'est
un nom que tout le monde connaît pas le
patine ça une très grosse consonance
mais genre au point qu'elle change de
nom je ne sais pas tu vois je trouve ça
je trouve ça étrange c'est pas parce que
genre je pense à par exemple la benedict
cumberbatch je faire un rapprochement
qui est hyper loin mais belgique comme
leur match en fait un nom qui est très
dur à porter car justement un de ses
aïeuls a fait des choses horribles du
coup c'est un nom très connu pour des
mauvaises choses au final et nuit du
coup à garder ce nom et c'est d'en faire
quelque chose de bien et je me dis que
ça aurait été sympa de faire cette même
symbolique avait créé mais en même temps
je comprends ce choix de skywalker par
exemple bon j'avoue le rapprochement
était quand même très très lointain donc
du coup je suis content n'empêche d'un
truc c'est que j'avais un peu imaginer
cette chose et du coup on est vraiment
la fin de la saga principale
techniquement du coup le conflit ce site
et jedi qui a toujours été techniquement
il prend fin et on a vraiment tout cette
symbolique avec palpatine où justement
tous les sites sont avec lui tous les
anciens sites et c'est tout le passé le
bac g il symbolise les sites à lui tout
seul pour cette fin comme aurait
symbolise tous les jedi tout
l'apprentissage médailles tous les jedi
qui ont vécu auparavant genre vraiment
l'ultime affrontement entre sith et jedi
et du coup elles sont nées sur une
véritable fin
car au final est ce que rêve vraiment
neutre à la fin c'est ça qui me perturbe
car du coup techniquement l'équilibré
n'est pas vraiment respectée puisque il
reste une jedi
les sites sont les jedi sont toujours
présents et du coup en fait c'est son
sabre qui me perturbe et je crois que
j'ai on a la réponse en vrai c'est que
près semble neutre car du coup elle
laisse les deux sabres de l'udc et de
l'eia sur tatouine en mode voilà les
jedi c'est la fin on referme
on retourne là où tout a commencé et
techniquement symbolique et elle est là
un sabre
qui semble plus ce genre faire neutre
genre il reste que les utilisateurs de
la force donc la fin des sites et des
jedi
maintenant passons à kayes lorraine
alors qu'eli lorraine c'était vraiment
trop obvious ce qui allait se passer par
rapport à kayes lorraine et je pense et
je suis même sûr que c'était l'une des
choses auxquelles jj abrams et ryan
johnson s'était mis d'accord dès le
début alors évidemment on a une
référence un peu à dark vador mais un
peu en inversé du coup puisque
dark vador a été sauvée par son enfant
l'udc qui l'a ramenée du bon côté alors
que là c'est plutôt l'inversé des
parents qui ont ramené caille lorraine
enfin ben solo du coup du bon côté donc
on est vraiment commune dans une sorte
de miroir avec cette nouvelle trilogie
avec justement en retz qui est une
palpatine gentille et du fou ben avec
l'histoire d'être sauvé par ses parents
quoi nous avons justement aussi la
référence à star wars est où ils
effacent en solo il le tue et cette
fois-ci non pas du tout c'est c'est ce
qui va le sauver et la rend la référence
à lennon on peut pas passer à côté
alors je suis pas con ce choix du tout à
ce que c'est je crois que c'est même
l'une des théories mais là plus des
premières j'ai imaginé et c'était même
trop obvious quoi 17 c'était trop je
pense
après j'ai vraiment toujours autant aimé
le personnage dans ce film là j'ai
plutôt content de ce qu'il est advenu et
nous sommes face à un très bon
personnage qu'elle règne au final
néanmoins c'est le problème je trouve du
film c'est tout va trop vite
et du coup son passage du bon côté ce
fait je trouve en ont vraiment une
demi-seconde quoi je sais pas trop
comment dire mais en fait la mort de
l'eia était touchante mais j'ai pas eu
le temps de l'assimiler en fait j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment j'ai trouvé ça
vraiment
pid et au final il semble y avoir
tellement de chose de caché sur les ja
j'étais même surpris alors j'ai pas si
ces prix de l'univers étendu je pense
très certainement mais du coup les liens
en tant que jedi
du coup c'est ça concorderait avec le 8
c'est pour expliquer lui très
certainement tout le fait qu'elles aient
des pouvoirs même si on savait qu'elle
avait des prêts de les prédispositions
par rapport à la force mais du coup dans
lui que là c'était très très montré
fortement
c'était peut-être la petite surprise
quoi donc voilà qu à l orange est
vraiment bien aimé ben solo surtout
campus au début c'est lui qui veut faire
venir ray du côté des sites et au final
c'est lui qui va du côté de ré et c'est
vraiment un peu comme dark vador et
lucau assez et a vraiment cette image
superposer c'était évident et en moins
chez un peu déçu qu'on n'ait pas eu
anakin je vous le cache pas pour moi je
voulais que ça soit vraiment un hacking
qui leur apparaissent et qui lui disent
j'en reviens du bon côté et a pas
compris ce que j'ai fait en fait tu as
tu penses dark vador mais tu sais pas ce
qui s'est passé après dark vador c'est
que je suis revenu enfin bon les
chevaliers de rennes
comment dire que ça va j'avoue que c'est
une déception j'étais très content de
les voir dès le début je me suis dit ok
ça va balancer du lourd et tout s'écoule
et au final bas nylon
même utilité que la garde prétorienne de
snacks et c'était sûr aussi c'est que
bayal et avoir une trahison entre les
cheveux et de rennes écailles lorraine
et aux finalistes sont tous déglingué
mais il travaillait comme la garde
prétorienne et encore la garde
prétorienne c'était un combat qui est
estimé comme vraiment sa job il faut se
l'avouer c'est un peu une déception
on voit là pour conclure l'essence même
de cette nouvelle trilogie est bonne je
trouve vraiment le problème des jedi et
des sites a toujours existé aujourd'hui
seuls des utilisateurs de la force
existent et sont présents beaucoup
beaucoup de choses était prévisible
voire un peu facile comme voilà le
retour de lando calrissian l'utilisation
son personnage suis pas trop en accord
avec mais bon c'était quand même très
sympa à voir mais en tout cas je suis
content voilà j'ai pas les mots s'il
juste leurs lots était pas nécessaire
pour moi je sais que beaucoup étaient à
fond là dessus mais vraiment pas moi pas
vraiment quoi et je pense que c'était
vraiment pour vous faire plaisir et
faire plaisir aux fans qu'ils ont fait
ça bon dans tous les cas je suis
vraiment content je suis content qu'on
soit arrivé à la fin et tout
écoutez ce qu'on ferait pas un petit
dernier trois théories un peu une team
pour honorer tout ça est bouclé la
boucle va commencer qu star wars c'est
ton fils nick star wars 9
dans tous les cas il faut que leur voix
pour comprendre plus de choses merci à
tous d'avoir écouté n'hésitez pas à
laisser votre plus beau coup double à
vous abonner à la chaîne à me suivre sur
twitter et instagram justement il le
concours et puis bah c'était art rock et
que le liner soit avec vous ali